donc bonjour officiellement de vive voix
pour cette convention d'enquête
médicament audition plénière
mes chers collègues nous poursuivons
aujourd'hui donc nos travaux pour une
autre par une audition conjointe des
représentants de plusieurs organismes
représentatifs des laboratoires et
entreprises du médicament
notre commission d'enquête c'est dans
son titre en tant recherché les liens
entre les phénomènes de pénurie et les
choix opérés par l'industrie
pharmaceutique ces dernières décennies
je précise qu'on regarde tous les liens
et pas que les vôtres
c'est pourquoi après avoir recueilli les
analyses des acteurs publics de la
régulation du médicament d'un certain
nombre de prescripteurs et d'experts
puis des pharmaciens il nous semblent
étaient essentiels de vous entendre
aujourd'hui
nous pouvons d'ores et déjà tirer les
premiers des premières auditions
quelques enseignements sur lesquels nous
souhaiterions vous entendre d'une part
il apparaît que si la formidable
augmentation de la demande
internationale de médicaments
constituent évidemment l'une des causes
importantes
excusez-moi des phénomènes de pénurie
on le vit actuellement ces derniers ne
peuvent toutefois pas être compris sans
s'intéresser à l'offre de médicaments et
à la manière dont elle est structurée au
niveau mondial en effet le secteur s'est
considérablement transformé depuis 30
ans la spécialisation croissante des
entreprises la délocalisation ou
l'externalisation des activités de
production et ce sur toute la chaîne du
médicament contribue à fractionner et à
fragiliser les chaînes
d'approvisionnement à cet égard
l'industrie française apparaît
aujourd'hui affaibli auparavant leader
notre pays n'occupe plus que la
quatrième place en Europe en matière de
production de médicaments le nombre
d'entreprises pharmaceutiques il y a
presque diminué de moitié la France
comptait dans les années 80 plus de 450
entreprises de production et non plus
que 240 aujourd'hui
la crise de la covid-19 a mis en lumière
l'importance de retrouver une certaine
souveraineté pharmaceutique il s'agit
aujourd'hui en France et en Europe je
précise d'un objectif largement partagé
d'autre part et alors que les prix des
médicaments matures est souvent mis en
avant parmi les causes de pénurie il
apparaît selon plusieurs études qu'il
n'est pas en France significativement
inférieur à celui des autres pays
européens
c'est comment dire une remarque générale
quand on regarde dans les détails c'est
un peu plus complexe
aucun lien entre niveau des prix en
France et apparition de phénomènes de
pénurie n'est par ailleurs solidement
démontré
chargez à vous peut-être de d'apporter
des éléments complémentaires l'existence
de pénurie dans un pays comme les
États-Unis ou dans le secteur
hospitalier en France en France tant à
démontrer que les prix négociés avec le
CEPS ne peuvent pas être tenus pour
facteur principal les difficultés
d'approvisionnement
Madame Corinne Blachier poisson
président de l'association des groupes
internationaux pour la pharmacie de
recherche à Gif farm Monsieur Didier
Véron président du G5 santé et enfin
Madame Karine Pinon président de
l'association des moyens laboratoires et
industries de santé la milice je vais
vous citer à chacun Toura tour la parole
pour un propos introductif de 5 minutes
le 5 comptes puisque il faut que nous
ayons le temps de cet échange de
l'échange après puis madame Laurence
Cohen rapporteur de notre commission
d'enquête vous posera une première série
de questions comme vous l'aurez compris
notre commission d'enquête entend
obtenir des réponses précises à des
questions précises et peut-être amener
des solutions efficaces à un problème
qui va croissant et s'aggravant depuis
une quinzaine d'années je précise que
nous vous adresserons à l'issue de
l'audition un questionnaire complet
auquel nous vous demanderons de répondre
par écrit avant le 14 avril
je précise également que cette audition
est diffusée en direct sur le site
internet du Sénat et qu'elle fera
l'objet d'un compte rendu publié avant
de vous donner la parole je vous
rappelle qu'un faux témoignage devant
notre commission d'enquête et passible
des plaines prévues aux articles 433 434
13 434 14 et 434-15 du code pénal je
vous invite chacun à votre tour à prêter
serment de dire toute la vérité rien que
la vérité en levant la main droite et en
disant je le jure monsieur l'amoureux
monsieur Borel Giraud madame lâcher
poisson monsieur Véro
madame Pinault
je vous remercie et je vais donc
maintenant vous donner successivement la
parole pour quelques minutes par
organisme ou institution et il me semble
que vous avez préparé
un propos structuré entre vous voilà
Monsieur Lamoureux
nous sommes répartis les temps
d'intervention de façon à ne pas avoir
d'effet de de redit d'un intervenant à
l'autre peut-être me permettrez-vous
pour compléter les quelques chiffres que
vous avez donné en introduction de
rappeler que le secteur du médicament on
a connu aucune croissance depuis une
douzaine d'années que le chiffre
d'affaires du secteur est quasiment
stable depuis 15 ans puisque PLFSS après
PLFSS nous avons des niveaux de
régulation qui ont véritablement
privé notre secteur de de cette
croissance qui fait qu'effectivement
aujourd'hui nous avons des difficultés
puisque je vous rappelle que chaque
année PLFSS s'apprp PLFSS le Parlement
vote à peu près entre 700 et 900
millions de baisse de prix par an
chiffre d'affaires rapportées à la
France
alors peut-être vous remercier aussi
d'avoir invité les différentes
composantes de notre industrie autour de
cette table et vous verrez que ce sont
des business models comme on dit qui
sont assez assez différents les uns des
autres
deuxième élément rappeler aussi que une
rupture d'approvisionnement c'est une
situation qui est complètement qui est
perçue de façon extrêmement dramatique
par nos entreprises puisque notre
vocation c'est d'apporter des solutions
thérapeutiques au lit des patients et
donc une rupture d'approvisionnement
n'est jamais une bonne nouvelle et
toujours quelque chose extrêmement
problématique pour nos entreprises donc
nous n'oublions jamais que les pénuries
ça concerne avant tous les patients et
nous sommes mobilisés sur ce sujet nous
faisons des propositions nous en avons
fait en 2019 nous continuons en faire
sur le sujet des pénuries deuxième
élément pour aller rapidement parce que
je vais pas vous assigner trop de
chiffres mais il est pas non plus
question de contester l'augmentation du
nombre de ruptures d'approvisionnement
c'est un phénomène que l'on constate et
qui est effectivement extrêmement
préoccupant beaucoup de raisons qui
permettent d'expliquer ça
disons que vous avez évoqué certaines
raisons vous avez parlé d'augmentation
de la demande mondiale oui c'est tout à
fait vrai la demande mondiale augmente
beaucoup plus rapidement que que l'offre
que les capacités de production pour
prendre un chiffre celui de 2021 les
câbles la capacité de production en
moyenne en France sur les cinq dernières
années c'est plus 6% la demande la
demande c'est plus 10%
et pourquoi et bien vieillissement de la
population développant de de cette
demande mondiale elle augmente du fait
du vieillissement de la population mais
pas que également du fait que beaucoup
de pays en développement se dotent de
système de protection sociale moderne il
y a un appel un appel d'air qui fait
qu'on a une demande mondiale très
dynamique et qui évidemment là la
production ne peut pas suivre le même
deuxième élément vous l'avez cité il est
tout à fait exact aussi la concentration
des fournisseurs de matières premières
et excipient
et c'est vrai qu'avec cette
concentration bien si on a un problème
sur un des sites une des usines
effectivement le risque de rupture
augmente et concernant les anciens
produits c'est vrai aussi que la
décroissance progressive du prix des
médicaments conjugués à l'accroissement
des normes européennes conduit à l'arrêt
de la production de certaines substances
actives en Europe et à la délocalisation
des productions dans les pays asiatiques
notamment l'un des et la Chine ou les
coûts de production sont plus réduits et
donc on a effectivement de nombreuses
molécules où on a que deux ou trois
fournisseurs dans le monde c'est un
constat qu'on nous partageons avec vous
peut-être un troisième élément que vous
n'avez pas évoqué c'est le temps de
cycle de production et les risques liés
à la complexité technologique c'est une
industrie qui a des techniques de
production de plus en plus complexes
notamment parce que de plus en plus de
médicaments sont issus des sciences du
vivant et des biotechnologies les
médicaments injectables les médicaments
stériles nécessitent des infrastructures
très sophistiquées des conditions de
production très strictes contrôle de
l'environnement stérilité des matières
premières et des produits finis du
matériel protection des personnels et la
moitié des médicaments d'intérêt
thérapeutique majeur déclarait à la NSM
pour tension d'approvisionnement ou pour
rupture sont des formes injectables et
toute perturbation liée soit un problème
industriel soit une fluctuation
inattendue des besoins du marché ne peut
pas être compensé s'agissant de produits
biologiques dans des brefs délais d'une
manière générale le temps de cycle d'un
médicament c'est fortement allongé et
donc s'accomplique encore l'adaptation
de la fabrication en fonction des
fluctuations imprévues du marché les
fabricants ont également mis en place
des systèmes d'assurance qualité
pharmaceutiques extrêmement exigeants
capables de détecter tout anomalie en
cours de production et la fabrication
est soumise à d'énormes européennes de
qualité et de sécurité très exigeante
qui augmente les risques non conformité
c'est un constat c'est pas du tout un
jugement de valeur de ma part et qui
rend ainsi impossible leur
commercialisation
par ailleurs nous ne sommes jamais à
l'abri d'un arrêt de production il y a
un problème de qualité un défaut de
personnel un accident industriels et
chaque fois qu'un fabricant est à
l'arrêt quelque part dans le monde il
met en tension l'ensemble de la chaîne
une fois qu'on a dit ça il existe
effectivement des spécificités
françaises alors nous allons diverger
évidemment sur les prix ce ne sont pas
nos données nos données nous montrent
que nous avons un écart de prix d'à peu
près 37 % par rapport à l'Allemagne ce
qui a plusieurs conséquences ça n'incite
pas les industriels investir en France
ça crée des difficultés lorsqu'il faut
prioriser l'approvisionnement en cas de
tension et par ailleurs les prix bas
encouragent évidemment l'exportation
parallèle avec un système d'achat
revente par des short liners vers les
marchés étrangers plus attractifs
deuxième raison c'est un gros débat
qu'on a eu avec le Parlement au sujet
des obligations de stockage on est
aujourd'hui sur un point d'équilibre
mais imposer des durées de stockage
longues sur des produits à faible valeur
ajoutée créer un risque de
décommercialisation de produits parce
que les coûts d'exploitation ne peuvent
plus être couverts par la par la valeur
de par la valeur des produits
troisième raison l'explosion des coûts
de production qui s'agisse des matières
premières désintrrants le principe actif
les emballages envers l'aluminium le
carton les dérivés du pétrole l'énergie
la masse salariale les médicaments sont
des produits à prix administrer et nous
n'avons pas la possibilité de répercuter
les augmentations de ces coups sur les
produits à la différence de la
quasi-totalité des autres secteurs et
donc nous sommes effectivement en
difficulté je vous donne deux chiffres
et je m'arrêterai là pour cette première
cette première introduction deux
chiffres
le prix on a parlé beaucoup de
l'amoxicilline le prix fabricant
hors-taxe de la boîte d'amoxicilline
c'est 76 centimes d'euros 76 centimes
d'euros comment voulez-vous garantir la
production la relocaliser la fortiori
lorsque les coûts de production expo
c'est une vraie difficulté je vous donne
un deuxième exemple prenons à soluté
courant à l'hôpital par exemple le
bicarbonate de sodium et bien le flacon
d'admilitres est vendu un euro40 en 2014
de fabricants gagnaient 13 centimes par
flacon aujourd'hui il en perd 17 la
question est simple c'est un fabricant
français quand il aura disparu où nous
approvisionnerons nous donc je pense
qu'il faut que le Sénat le Parlement de
façon générale prennent la mesure des
difficultés et enfin on parlait des
génériques la marge des produits
génériques c'est 0,3% en moyenne
donc face à cette situation ce qu'on
observe c'est que certains pays
l'Allemagne le Portugal
aujourd'hui encore la Suède ont annoncé
des mesures de
revalorisation
des produits anciens en France il y a eu
des annonces qui ne se sont pas encore
concrétisés et dont on se demande si
elles seront suffisantes pour faire face
aux enjeux voilà pour les éléments de
diagnostic donc je reviendrai si vous me
le permettez à la fin sur les pistes de
solution qu'on peut ébaucher mais je
voudrais tout d'abord donner la parole
sur
un petit peu l'analyse comporte sur les
politiques publiques qui sont menées en
commençant par Didier Véron le président
du G5
santé c'est un cercle de réflexion qui
rassemble les dirigeants des principales
entreprises françaises de santé que son
bioMérieux guerbé Epson le LFB Pierre
Fabre Sanofi servi et T1 les entreprises
du G5 sont un atout pour la souveraineté
sanitaire de la France en effet elle
dispose de plus de 50 usines en France
une trentaine de titres de recherche en
France chaque année elles investissent 3
milliards et demi d'euros en recherche
et en développement premier partenaire
de la recherche publique française
ces dépenses représentaient trois quarts
des investissements de secteur elles
investissent également un milliard
d'euros par an dans le domaine
industriel en France
la crise sanitaire a enfin permis la
prise de conscience de l'importance de
la souveraineté sanitaire et des
fragilités de la France sujet dont le G5
santé avait alerté les pouvoirs publics
depuis longtemps
la réponse politique à cette crise
sanitaire a été forte et rapide avec
France Roland notamment la baisse des
impôts de production des appels à
projets des appels à manifestation
d'intérêt nous pouvons que nous
féliciter de ce début de politique
industrielle avec notamment 18 projets
de rapatriement en France d'une
production de principes actifs retenue
35 molécules concernées
avec après la crise sanitaire l'enjeu
est désormais d'armée la France et
l'Europe pour lutter contre les pénuries
et renforcer la souveraineté sanitaire
mais nous attendons toujours la liste
des médicaments dit critiques à
sécuriser de façon prioritaire cette
liste permettrait de cibler les actions
à conduire pour assurer la sécurité
approvisionnement pour les patients en
France
si nous soutenons cette politique
favorable dans un investissements en
amont le problème selon nous est
davantage en aval sur le niveau bas du
prix d'achat du médicament par les
pouvoirs publics en France combien de
mentionner Philippe Lamoureux notons
nous notons ainsi une incohérence entre
les politiques publiques la politique
industrielle de soutien secteur et la
politique budgétaire la production de
médicaments demande des investissements
très importants et ceci est d'autant
plus vrai en France et en Europe ou le
coût et les contraintes sont bien
supérieures comparés notamment à ce
qu'ils sont en Chine ou en Inde il n'est
donc pas simple pour un industriel de
maintenir sa production en France de
décider de nouvelles investissements
pour augmenter la production de produits
critiques ou bien même de relocaliser en
France lorsque l'on craint
que ce ne soit pas rentable voire à
perte du fait d'une régulation
économique bien trop forte en France
notamment avec des baisses de prix
importantes les entreprises du G5 santé
ont fait réaliser une étude par le bip
qui démontre que nos 8 entreprises
françaises ne s'en sortent aujourd'hui
uniquement par nos positions à l'export
on va actualiser cette étude mais je
peux vous donner les chiffres de
précédentes qui étaient sur la période
2010 à 2017 pour nos 8 entreprises sur
cette période donc 2010 2017 chiffre
d'affaires France de nos entreprises de
8 entreprises et moins 16%. chiffre
d'affaires à l'export + 6 % ce qui
permet une stabilisation notre chiffre
d'affaires total sur cette même période
2010-2017 on a maintenu nos emplois
industriels en France stabiliser nos
installations industrielles alors même
que notre profitabilité notre excellents
brutes d'exploitation en France a chuté
de 32%
en tant qu'entreprise française notre
marché domestique devrait au contraire
être notre plateforme pour développer
nos actions à l'international je
souhaite enfin terminer par un exemple
concret qui montre que la loi votée par
vous les sénateurs et les députés prend
parfois beaucoup de temps avant d'être
appliqué il s'agit d'articles 65 de la
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale pour 2022 voté grâce à la
compréhension des difficultés de notre
pays en matière industrielle par vous
les parlementaires pour rappel cet
article de loi mentionne que la fixation
du prix d'un médicament peut également
tenir compte de la sécurité
d'approvisionnement du marché français
que garantit l'implantation des sites de
production
le comité économique des produits de
santé peut désormais tenir compte de
l'implantation des sites de production
pour réviser fixer le prix d'un
médicament ce qui va dans le bon sens un
an et demi après l'adoption de cet
article par vous les parlementaires le
CEPS vient enfin d'officialiser sa
doctrine d'application après des
arbitats des arbitrages rendus tout
récemment par les cabinets ministériels
cependant cette doctrine s'applique à ce
jour uniquement aux produits nouveau ce
ne sont pas ces produits nouveaux qui
posent problème de pénurie
d'approvisionnement il faut donc que cet
article de loi puisse aussi s'appliquer
pour réviser à la hausse le prix des
médicaments déjà commercialisés des
médicaments dit critiques la loi ne
prévoyant pas d'ailleurs aucune
restriction dans son application
il faut revoir rapidement donc notre
politique de régulation et de
financement des médicaments remonter le
prix d'un certain nombre d'entre eux qui
du fait de l'inflation ne sont plus
économiquementiables s'ils sont produits
en France ces décisions de hausse de
prix doivent être prises rapidement elle
permettront d'éviter des exportations
parallèles de nos médicaments dans les
pays européens ou les prix sont plus
élevés ce qui peut être source de
tension et de rupture
d'approvisionnement en France
c'est hausse de prix médicament sont
également indispensables si nous ne
voulons pas fermer demain les lignes de
production non rentables sur le
territoire national en résumé s'il avait
trois positions à retenir ce serait les
suivantes mettre en oeuvre effectivement
l'article 65 de la loi de financement de
la sécurité sociale pour 2022 pour la
prise en compte de l'implantation des
sites de production dans la fixation et
la révision des prix des médicaments
finaliser la liste des médicaments dit
critiques appliquer rapidement des
hausses de prix sur les médicaments à
Fort en jeu d'indépendance sanitaires
sur ce dernier point je vais donc passer
la parole à ma collègue Karine pinement
président de l'âme Nice et je vous
remercie de votre attention c'est moi
qui passe la parole
je reconnais il pourrait péter les
choses pour qu'elle soit comprise madame
Karine Pinon s'il vous plaît
bonjour donc moi je représente la miss
donc vous l'avez dit l'association des
moyens français des petits moyens
français on représente à peu près 168
PME françaises qui ont comme Katar
caractéristiques excusez moi de créer
24000 emplois sur le sol français et
également de produire 34,4% des MITM
consommer en France qu'est-ce qu'un MITM
c'est un médicament d'intérêt
thérapeutique majeur exactement
qu'est-ce que c'est c'est toutes les
pathologies chroniques que l'on a
essentiellement je l'hypertension le
diabète
toutes ces pathologies qui affectent 95%
des gens qui prennent des médicaments
passé 50 ans
et c'est des médicaments également dont
quand on a une interruption on a un ce
qu'on appelle le pronostic vital du
patient qui est en jeu donc c'est MITM
la miss et les PME françaises en
produisent 34,4 % et avec une
caractéristique c'est que 55% de la
production est faite en France et 90% en
Europe donc là on a on va dire qu'on est
les petits frères du G5
considérant ça
très clairement l'indépendance sanitaire
c'est quelque chose qui qui nous touche
particulièrement et donc on est plutôt
sur ce qu'on appelle des produits
matures des produits donc encore une
fois qui font le quotidien des Français
quand on a de l'hypertension on a du
diabète où on souffre d'épilepsie enfin
plein de choses comme ça
c'est mes médicaments on l'a vu ont eu
des baisses de prix successives tout au
long des années et dans un système qui
consistait à dire que on finançait
l'innovation par des réductions de prix
des produits mature on arrive en bout de
course du système c'est qu'on a un des
produits matures qui sont arrivés à un
nouveau à un niveau de prix qui ne
permettent plus d'être économiquement
viable et qui sont notre analyse est
formelle pour beaucoup sur ces causes de
rupture
alors les caractéristiques on a vu des
baisses de prix successives qui en
parallèle ont
dans le même temps je dirais on a eu des
augmentations des
normes de qualité de réglementaires
comme le disait Philippe nul ne conteste
mais quand on met en place une
sériealisation c'est à peu près 20
centimes par boîte tout ceci a été
absolument absorbé par les fabricants
quand on parle des recherches de
nitrosamines quand on parle d'énormes
icchu 3D tout ceci a été je dirais au
niveau du coût de la sécurité sociale
totalement neutre et absorbé par les
fabricants
et on arrive maintenant dans un contexte
inflationniste qui est je dirais qui
vient s'ajouter à tout ça dans un
contexte déjà difficile et on a parlé de
l'augmentation des intrants donc
qu'est-ce qu'un intrant c'est les
matières premières c'est le vert c'est
le carton c'est l'aluminium c'est tout
ce qui sert à la fabrication du
médicament on estime à peu près qu'on
est entre 15 et 20% sur les deux
dernières années en matière de
d'augmentation d'intrant c'est à dire
purement la piaille maintenant il y a
des cas très spécifiques et on peut pas
généraliser c'est des il y a des cas où
vous allez avoir moi j'ai eu sur
certains produits plus de 300%
d'augmentation sur sur un apial après
vous avez également tout ce qui est
augmentation de l'aluminium du vert qui
sont dramatiques et on arrive aussi
effectivement dans une concurrence
industrielle qui fait que par exemple
sur le verre aujourd'hui on est non
seulement à des augmentations qui façon
de plus de 600% mais en plus on a des
temps d'approvisionnement qui sont de
plus en plus longs donc tout ceci fait
que on a des augmentations très
significatives juste pour te donner un
exemple très concret de l'augmentation
du coût de l'énergie au niveau d'un d'un
CDMO par exemple que je connais il avait
à peu près 300K euros de coûts d'énergie
en 2021 aujourd'hui il est à 854 euros
donc voilà c'est
ensuite on a l'augmentation de la masse
salariale donc on est aussi dans une
industrie qui est extrêmement
soumise aux mêmes aléas que tout le
monde c'est à dire que on a en face de
nous des gens notamment dans les usines
qui demandent des augmentations de
salaire et qui sont parfaitement
légitimes au regard de l'inflation que
l'on a et donc du coup et bien on a en
moyenne une augmentation salariale qui
est plutôt autour de 7%
si on veut être compétitif parce que
l'objectif c'est de faire tourner les
usines et qu'on aille des gens qui
acceptent de travailler pour nous donc
tout ceci fait que et bien votre
boulanger par exemple quand il décide il
a son cou d'électricité qui augmente il
a son coup de sa farine qui augmente il
a le coude ça ça de s'avant de ce qu'il
augmente il augmente sa baguette et ben
nous c'est pas possible nous on a des
prix fixes et qui fait que derrière et
bien nous la baisse de marche elle est
totalement pour nous donc on considère
que sur des produits je dirais
classique si on a une marge brute qui
est de moins de 20% on ne peut pas faire
face à tout ce qui est coût de
réglementaire coup de la qualité etc
j'ai juste vous donner un exemple parce
que c'est c'est assez intéressant donc
Philippe vous a donné tout à l'heure
l'exemple du bicarbonate de sodium vous
savez le bicarbonate de sodium c'est
quand vous allez à l'hôpital vous avez
par exemple vous devez avoir une
perfusion de d'Ant ibiotiques on vous on
vous met pas directement l'antibiotique
directement dans votre veine on va le
mettre dans une poche de soluté qui va
derrière
diffuser tout au long de la journée
d'accord donc ce bicarbonate de sodium
vous êtes d'accord avec moi c'est
absolument indispensable et bien le
Bigard de sodium on nous demande de le
vendre à 1,40 pour 1,40 on nous demande
d'avoir un flacon de 500 ml en vert
stérile
et stéréalisé ça veut dire que chaque
flacon de bicarbonate de sodium on doit
savoir où il se trouve un euro 40 je
vais pas vous refaire la fronde de la
baguette on a à peu près au coût de la
baguette d'accord donc typiquement
aujourd'hui ce 1,40 de bicarbonate de
sodium le fabricant aujourd'hui il met 1
euro 74 pour le produit c'est à dire
qu'on lui demande de vendre moins cher
que ce que ça la coûte je vais vous
donner un autre exemple un produit que
moi je commercialise on me demande de
fabriquer pour 0,89 centimes une boîte
de 50 comprimés qui sont utilisés ces
comprimés je vais pas sortir la marque
qui sont utilisés dans les EHPAD pour
calmer les personnes qui sont en démence
sénile d'accord qui sont utilisés aussi
dans les prisons pour calmer les
prisonniers qui sont en cure de
désintoxication d'accord donc on me
demande de produire enfin de vendre à 89
centimes 50 comprimés qui sont dans des
dans des blisters aluminium et d'avoir
tout tout le suivi réglementaire et
qualité que l'on doit avoir
le pharmacien lui quand il voit devant
cette boîte il a un euro 01 de marge de
dispensation
d'accord donc ça veut dire que le
pharmacien je suis pharmacienne donc je
il y a rien contre les pharmacies dans
ce que je vais dire le pharmacien qui
qui se tourne pour ouvrir son tiroir
pour chercher la boîte il gagne plus
d'argent
que moi qui derrière moi je gagne 12
centimes par boîte d'accord donc moi je
gagne 12 centimes Bouygues pour tout
fabriquer et derrière c'est 12 centimes
de marge brute je dis encore barge brute
parce que derrière il faut que je paye
aussi les gens du réglementaire de la
qualité etc d'accord donc ça c'est
totalement impensable je veux dire c'est
derrière on peut pas gagner la
conséquence de quoi c'est que nous on
décide derrière de des rembourser le
produit puisque nous on ne peut plus on
peut plus assurer la production de ce
produit on décide du coup de se dire bah
tant pis ce produit sera mis à
disposition mais ne sera plus remboursé
parce que on ne peut plus continuer à
commercialiser à sa à ce niveau là de
prix donc oui les ruptures elles sont
liées à un problème économique derrière
il y a des ruptures mais il va y avoir
aussi des arrêts de commercialisation
puisque et bien produire à perte c'est
quelque chose on ne peut plus faire donc
arrête commercialisation ça veut dire
aussi diminution de ce qu'on appelle
l'arsenal thérapeutique pour un médecin
c'est à dire que il aura moins de choix
pour pouvoir traiter ses patients
très bien merci beaucoup
Monsieur Laurent Borel Giraud merci
madame la Présidente on va diffuser
quelques
supports pour faciliter la intervention
je crois que c'est en cours je vais
démarrer
le j'aime réunit les entreprises de
médicaments génériques et exploitant ou
fabricants qui agissent en France
nos médicaments alors c'est sur la page
suivante nos médicaments sont dispensés
en pharmacie en ville ou à l'hôpital
sont des médicaments du quotidien qui
couvrent un grand nombre de pathologies
alors l'industrie du générique a des
spécificités elle se caractérise
notamment par un volume et un
portefeuille de produits importants
on peut dire plus d'un médicament sur
deux dispensés en officine est un
médicament générique un niveau de prix
bas et une faible rentabilité
à l'image de chiffres de référence qui
ont été publiées en 2022 un impact
significatif en termes d'économie pour
l'assurance maladie le développement du
marché générique permet une économie
estimée à peu près chaque année de 2
milliards d'euros en France
enfin nos laboratoires proposent une
offre
diversifiée
d'exploitant de multiples sources de
production
ainsi qu'une implantation largement
majoritaire en Europe et forte en France
qui améliore notre capacité à gérer les
risques de rupture
sur la page suivante nous confirmons
évidemment le contexte qui nous réunit
aujourd'hui et sans revenir dessus
malheureusement notre point de vue et
que la situation constatée est durable
elle est la conséquence de CO
structurelle qui fragilise la chaîne
d'approvisionnement des médicaments à
faible marge et de situations
conjoncturelles aggravante qui augmente
les risques et les pénuries
alors je voudrais revenir sur le
diagnostic avec un axe
identique à mes à mes confrères
collègues et en ajoutant quelques
éléments nous alertons les autorités
depuis plusieurs années sur le poids
excessif de la régulation économique qui
fragilise l'industrie du générique et
première conséquence
augmente le risque de pénurie
cette première conséquence qui est
placée ici sur sur la gauche elle fait
vite appel à deux autres conséquences le
risque imminent d'une réduction de
l'offre d'acteurs et de produits sur le
marché ainsi qu'une difficulté
persistante à investir dans la
séguration sécurisation de nos
approvisionnements alors pourquoi parce
qu'aujourd'hui parmi nos adhérents nous
recensons plus de 700 présentations
pharmaceutiques qui sont peu ou non
rentables ça veut dire qu'à court ou
moyen terme nous envisageons leur arrêt
de commercialisation ça représente à peu
près 12% des volumes de générique
aujourd'hui commercialisé qui sont
essentiellement pour leur grande
majorité des produits et mitaines
et puis pourquoi difficulté d'investir
parce que le faible niveau de prix des
génériques limite notre capacité en tant
que laboratoire à trouver des
fournisseurs sur notre territoire qui
acceptent de fabriquer à ces prix
compétitifs dans un contexte qu'on a
expliqué où les capacités mondiales de
production sont insuffisantes donc ça
c'est une somme de causes et puis pour
comprendre je vais prendre quelques
instants pour expliquer les conséquences
ou alors en tout cas dans les causes
après les conséquences
je reviens quelques instants sur
l'origine de cette pression économique
et constante qui est croissante sur les
médicaments génériques qui sont par
nature à Marge faible depuis 10 ans
c'est le premier point ce qui est remis
en cause c'est une baisse de prix
excessive depuis 10 ans notre régulation
économique a fondé le modèle du marché
des médicaments génériques exclusivement
sur la maîtrise des coûts
ça veut dire que divers outils de
fixation de prix se succèdent pour
abaisser autant que possible le prix des
médicaments génériques et ainsi les
dépenses de l'assurance maladie ça a
plutôt bien fonctionné de ce point de
vue là ont été diminués par deux entre
2010 et 2020 alors que les volumes de
médicaments ont augmenté
au cours de la deuxième au cours de
cette même période et c'est le deuxième
point dans les causes nous avons absorbé
ça a été dit des coûts de production
additionnels qui t'ont qui sont issus
premièrement de nouvelles
réglementations toujours plus exigeantes
pour de bonnes raisons pour des raisons
valables d'un point de vue de la
sécurité de la qualité mais qui ont un
coût en termes de production et puis
évidemment on a tous vécu des événements
externes qui sont représentés ici tels
que le brexit le covid les plans de 0
covid dans certaines régions du monde où
les relations internationales qui ont
rajouté de la complexité réorganiser nos
chaînes de production qui sont autant
d'occasions en plus de la réglementation
de rupture additionnelle et de coûts
additionnels qu'il faut gérer
réorganiser là où je vais en venir et
c'est la troisième cause
qui entraîne les ruptures c'est
finalement la réaction de nos industries
face à cette situation afin de s'adapter
l'industrie des médicaments génériques a
optimiser ces chaînes
d'approvisionnement elle a optimisé ces
sites de fabrication elle a optimisé ses
capacités de production afin de contenir
un étau entre des prix de vente qui
baisse et des prix de production qui
augmentent et finalement après ces
optimisations auxquelles on a ajouté
aussi des recherches de composants moins
chères souvent
en dehors de l'Europe nos
usines sont maintenant exploitées un
taux d'utilisation maximum pour rester
rentable autrement dit il n'y a pas de
capacité
inutilisées sur nos chaînes
d'approvisionnement pour faire face à
des poussées occasionnels de demandes ou
à des événements imprévisibles
ça veut dire aussi que malgré des
scottes des stocks de sécurité
organisées nous ne sommes beaucoup plus
sensibles aux fluctuations et beaucoup
plus exposées aux pénuries
enfin et il s'agit ici pour notre
segment d'activité du accentuation
majeure récente qui vient s'ajouter à
l’éto-économique c'est l'application de
la clause de sauvegarde au périmètre des
génériques depuis 2019 et l'augmentation
extraordinaire de son montant
encore aujourd'hui comme depuis trois
années nous alertons sur l'impasse
économique d'une partie grandissante du
portefeuille générique sous la pression
économique d'un modèle qui persiste à
taxer les produits génériques à faible
marge pour financer la croissance des
dépenses dont il n'est non seulement pas
à l'origine mais par ailleurs qu'il rend
possible par les économies qui génèrent
j'ajoute à ce sujet économique deux
points importants
premièrement certains points de
réglementation pharmaceutique freinent
la mise en oeuvre de solutions
productives dans nos usines dont nous
cherchons tellement
à dégager des capacités additionnelles
certains sont spécifiques au marché
français et donc pénalise la production
de produits français dans ses usines
qu'elles soient en France ou en Europe
nous travaillons évidemment avec la NSM
et l'OMA sur ces sujets mais il me
semble qu'il faudrait accélérer ses
décisions pour permettre d'éviter plus
de situations de rupture et j'ajoute une
voie de plus parmi des personnes que
vous aurez auditionnées
mon interrogation et je voudrais
souligner la pratique d'appel d'offres
publics basées sur des politiques
d'achat dangereuses tant qu'elles ne
sont pas contrebalancées par des
politiques d'approvisionnement
responsables à ce sujet j'ai pu citer
quelques critères d'attribution que nous
appelons de nos vœux qui sont toujours
pas appliqués et j'y ajoute la
prévisibilité et les délais sans
lesquels nous détruisons de la valeur
industrielle et nous détruisons des
capacités de production pour ne pas dire
des produits dans certains cas
alors quelques solutions rapidement sur
lesquelles nous pourrons revenir si vous
le souhaitez en quatre volets le premier
c'est d'établir une liste de médicaments
prioritaires ça a déjà été dit
j'insisterai sur un point clarifions
l'objectif de cette liste est-ce que
nous souhaitons
confirmer sécuriser un
après-visionnement ordinaire ou de la
gestion de crise est-ce que nous
souhaitons relocaliser ou simplement
sécuriser nos approvisionnements on ne
répondra pas de la même manière à ces
différentes questions il y a quand même
un point qui nous intéresse pour ces
produits là c'est de sanctuariser les
conditions économiques et qu'elles
soient pérennes dans le temps quel que
soit les modalités qui seront utilisées
le deuxième point il vise
essentiellement à répondre aux causes
économiques que j'ai citées précédemment
et qui consiste à préserver la
résilience permise par l'offre générique
et autoriser l'investissement des
chaînes de d'approvisionnement un
ensemble de points qui ont été partagés
avec la mission financement et
régulation des produits de santé et que
vous pouvez lire ici
enfin deux autres volets qui sont à mon
sens très important parce qu'il regroupe
des actions opérationnelles non
économiques qui peuvent changer
significativement notre capacité à
éviter des ruptures ou au moins en
atténuer l'impact le premier point il
fait appel à une simplification
réglementaire il faudrait supprimer les
exceptions françaises qui rendent nos
produits plus complexes à fabriquer et
interdisent le recours à une meilleure
productivité dans des usines françaises
européennes ou Europe nous devrions
aussi accélérer les travaux en vue d'un
accès digital aux notices par un QR code
s'il était possible en utilisant un pack
européen qui permettrait à nos
entreprises de mieux répondre aux enjeux
de protection des médicaments en
particulier ceux destinés aux hôpitaux
qu'ils soient génériques ou non
et enfin en vue de diminuer des causes
de rupture qui sont parfois longues il
serait intéressant d'envisager des
flexibilités réglementaires dans
certains cas de figure pour favoriser
l'utilisation de production faite chez
nos voisins mais que nous nous retenons
de faire en France pour des raisons
économiques
et le dernier point pour terminer nous
recommandons développer suite au progrès
en termes d'anticipation et de vigilance
que nous avons conseillé constaté
consécutivement au décret stock nous
souhaitons développer des conditions de
transparence et de collaboration dans la
chaîne pharmacie qui ont déjà été
évoqués avec les pharmaciens en
particulier autour de la transparence
pour encadrer le partage des alertes et
accélérer la mobilisation de stock quand
il existe des alternatives il s'agit de
recherche et de l'agilité et aussi
d'impliquer plus les distributeurs et
les dispensateurs dans le la gestion de
l'information en termes de coopération
aussi ce que nous avons noté c'est que
certaines crises qui impliquent
plusieurs acteurs qui impliquent
plusieurs canaux de distribution sont
particulièrement compliqués à gérer et
qu'il faut là aussi qu'on continue à
progresser en ayant tous les
interlocuteurs autour de la table
merci
madame lâcher poisson
merci madame la Présidente alors donc je
représente agifam qui est l'association
des laboratoires américains présents en
France nous regroupons 15 sociétés qui
sont de taille variable nous avons des
très grands groupes historiques comme
MSD genssen ou Pfizer des sociétés
taille moyenne comme celle que je
préside amgènes un laboratoire
biotechnologie et des petites sociétés
récemment installées en France qui ont
un ou deux
une ou deux molécules commercialisées
alors nous sommes principalement des
laboratoires d'innovation mais certains
d'entre eux ont des portefeuilles
historiques de médicaments qui sont
devenus matures qui ont perdu leurs
brevets qu'ils ont gardé dans leur dans
leur portefeuille donc nous avons une
connaissance aussi du sujet des produits
matures mais je vais me concentrer
surtout sur le sujet de l'innovation
aujourd'hui qui sera complémentaire de
l'intervention de mes collègues nous
sommes très présents en oncologie
hématologie dans les les vaccins mais
aussi les maladies chroniques
on continue à apporter des innovations
dans les maladies mentales ou aussi bien
dans les maladies cardiovasculaires ou
cardio rénale nous représentons agiferme
représente plus de 50 % des accès
précoce en France donc ce qui est un
signe aussi de d'une innovation
continue et nous sommes amenés à avoir
énormément de collaboration avec des
centres de recherche fondamentales en
France ou et très actif aussi avec les
centres de recherche cliniques qui sont
aussi un moyen de diffuser l'innovation
avant la commercialisation classique
alors je voudrais rappeler que donc les
tensions d'approvisionnement que l'on
voit aujourd'hui pour les produits
matures elles peuvent aussi apparaître
de manière conjoncturelle sur les
produits innovants
pour trois raisons que nous avons
identifié le premier c'est que ce sont
des niveaux d'exigence très élevés pour
les processus de fabrication qui
nécessitent à la fois des compétences
pointues à la fois biologique chimique
et parce que oui je n'ai pas mentionné
mais nous nous couvrons à la fois des
molécules biologiques et des molécules
chimiques et aussi les MTI les
médicaments de thérapie innovantes
telles que définie par l'agence
européenne donc ce premier point de
d'exigence des processus de fabrication
qui peut qui peut demander des
investissements importants des et un
temps de validation et de mise au point
aussi assez long
deuxièmement ensuite il y a le sujet du
passage à l'échelle quand on décide de
passer à une un stade industriel ça
représente aussi des délais
incompressibles avec des investissements
extrêmement importants qui peuvent
retarder la fabrication et des
investissements des mises au point de
processus et aussi des validations par
les agences
sanitaires donc tout ça mi bout à bout
peuvent retarder en effet la mise à
disponibilité de certains produits et
pour finir la multiplicité des
composants aussi qui rentrent qui
rentrent dans la fabrication d'une
molécule aujourd'hui je sais que par
exemple Pfizer a l'habitude de citer que
pour son vaccin ARN il faut environ 270
à 280 composants donc
évidemment s'il manque un de ses
composants dans la chaîne tout cela un
impact sur l'ensemble sur en bout de
course la mise à disposition du vaccin
je voudrais prendre un exemple pour
montrer que
nous avons justement cette question de
la mise de la concentration de certaines
compétences à un niveau mondial on a
beaucoup entendu parler au moment de la
vaccination et des vaccins ARN des
vecteurs viraux on avait besoin de
vecteurs viral pour produire la RN
messager et il y a très peu de
producteurs au niveau mondial de
vecteurs virales or le ce même vecteur
viral on en a besoin pour produire les
quartiers saines qui sont donc des
médicaments thérapie innovantes je vois
que vous connaissez et en fait
clairement évidemment la priorité a été
donnée à la production des vaccins en
2021 2022 ce qui a eu un effet de sur la
production des cartes ficelles qui sont
passées en second et donc là on a on a
vu clairement une baisse de la
production de l'administration des
quartiers celles du fait de ce manque de
vecteurs virales donc
on a aussi des arbitrages à faire qui se
font alors bien sûr là il est pas
tellement de discussions à voir
puisqu'on était dans une pandémie
mondiale mais un arbitrage qui se fait
au niveau mondial entre les différents
producteurs ce qui peut bien sûr ne pas
être compréhensible de la part du public
je voudrais aussi rappeler une chose qui
me semble un peu du bon sens mais qui
est qui me frappe toujours c'est en fait
la difficulté à prévoir les besoins de
production
parce qu'en fait aujourd'hui on a donc
ça a été très bien dit une demande
mondiale qui peut avoir des hausses
conjoncturelles absolument imprévisibles
il suffit de prendre le sujet de la
moticine récemment est-ce que est-ce
qu'il devait croître déjà il y a avant
il y a six mois personne n'était
vraiment prêt à ça est-ce que la demande
allée croître de 10 20 30 ou 60%
personne n'était capable en effet de
l'anticiper donc c'est vrai que
oui mais après quand vous êtes face à
une vous êtes vous planifiez une
production vous devez donner un chiffre
précis et la croissance ça va de 0 à X
et donc ça en tant qu'industriel je peux
dire que c'est un sujet qui est pas si
simple et qui demande en effet à une
très très bonne proximité entre les
acteurs commerciaux au sein de
l'entreprise et les acteurs les ceux qui
sont dans les usines et ça ça c'est un
petit sujet opérationnel qui a des
conséquences si les mal gérées qui
peuvent avoir des conséquences très
importantes alors deuxième point que je
souhaite souligner au titre de la gif
femme c'est que nous voulons mettre en
avant enfin souligner le fait que la
sécurité d'approvisionnement ne rime pas
avec lieu de production donc en fait le
fait disposer de chaînes de production
localisées intégralement en France n'est
pas une garantie que nous aurons tous
les médicaments pour tous les patients
tous les jours et tous les médicaments
dont nous avons besoin vu aujourd'hui le
nombre de molécules qui existent qui
sont à la disposition des praticiens
français vu la vue le nombre de
composants qui rentrent dans la
fabrication de ces molécules il n'est
pas réaliste de penser qu'on va pouvoir
rapatrier toute la production de tous
ces produits donc indépendamment du fait
que ça a un intérêt industriel certain
que ça peut permettre de répondre à un
certain nombre de
d'enjeux surtout pour des molécules
anciennes qui ont été largement et très
bien décrites il reste en tout cas un
certain nombre de produits qui viendront
d'autres sites de production surtout
qu'on a intérêt à voir
des toujours un site de production
principale on peut dire mais qui soit
couvert par un site de production de
d'urgence et ça je peux je peux donner
l'exemple en effet dans ma société nous
avons une usine d'anticorps monoclonaux
qui a été frappée par un ouragan aux
États-Unis il y a quelques années et
heureusement nous avions une usine
d'urgence qui a pu du jour au lendemain
reprendre cette production qui avait été
complètement stoppée en une nuit
d'ouragan donc c'est clair qu'il faut
avoir de toute manière des sites de
soutien des sites sur lesquels on peut
rapatrier la production très rapidement
donc en fait nous pensons que il est
surtout pertinent de créer de la
flexibilité au niveau européen au moins
européen entre les sites de production
pour être sûr que l'on puisse se
répondre à cette demande à cette demande
qui je le redis peut quand même
connaître un grand nombre de de
variations
sachant que bien entendu en tant
qu'industriel nous cherchons toujours à
répondre aux marchés mais aussi nous
voulons nous prémunir d'un risque qui
est celui de détruire des produits donc
ça c'est quand même la Constitution et
je veux revenir sur le sujet la
constitution des stocks de sécurité
aujourd'hui nous avons donc deux mois de
stock de sécurité ce qui nous paraît une
mesure pertinente et nous ne poussons
pas du tout à l'augmentation de cette de
cette quantité parce que nous pensons
que d'abord sera un effet délétère sur
les autres pays européens qui
risque de surenchère entre les pays et
deuxièmement et cela risque de
d'augmenter le risque de destruction
massive de stock non utilisé puisque je
reviens toujours au fait que les
prévisions c'est difficile à l'exception
d'un marché qui reste stable ce qui est
quand même le cas de très peu de marché
aujourd'hui on peut avoir des marchés
qui peuvent aller à la hausse mais on
peut aussi avoir des marchés qui
arrivent à la baisse qui lui connaissent
une baisse soudaine ou ou plus marqué
que anticipé parce qu'il y a des
concurrents parce qu'il y a eu un
changement de stratégie thérapeutique et
donc ça aussi ça peut nous amener des
fois à détruire des produits ce que je
pense d'un point de vue éthique tout à
fait préjudiciable et que les patients
pourraient pas comprendre pardon
excusez-moi
c'est parce que c'est pour raccourcir
donc voilà moi c'était je voulais finir
sur notre recommandation c'est une
réponse européenne concertée entre les
États membres sur des critères qui
permettent de définir le caractère
stratégique des produits et les besoins
au mieux très bien merci merci beaucoup
je vais immédiatement donner la parole à
notre rapporteur Laurence Cohen
oui je sais que c'est très frustrant de
vous dire de parler que 5 minutes chacun
et chacune aurait envie de parler bien
plus longtemps d'ailleurs vous avez tout
et tous dépassés les 5 minutes mais nous
nous sommes aussi très frustrés s'il ne
pouvons pas vous poser les questions
parce que c'est une commission d'enquête
vous avez prêté serment et c'est
important que chacun chacune puisse vous
poser des questions vous avez commencé
finalement vos introductions votre qui
était en fait
collégiale puisque vous aviez pu vous
répartir les sujets que vous alliez vous
alliez aborder sur le fait que
effectivement il y avait eu une
politique de délocalisation très
importante et qui faisait en gros que la
délocalisation concentrait se
concentrait sur deux pays je résume la
Chine et l'Inde et que c'était grosso
modo 80% des principes des principes
actifs et ça c'est pas nouveau c'est
depuis une trentaine d'années donc c'est
une externalisation qui est extrêmement
extrêmement importante et
moi je voudrais vous interroger sur le
fait que cette stratégie vous en avez
été
les faire de lance puisque pour
maintenir effectivement
les coûts qui vous semblaient devoir
être réduit vous avez externalisé
et vous avez donc fait cette stratégie
choisi cette stratégie donc dans quelle
mesure cette stratégie vous avez choisie
vous paraît responsable ou pas de
l'augmentation des phénomènes de pénurie
parce que comme vous l'avez dit vous
avez en même temps non seulement
délocaliser externalisée mais vous avez
aussi concentré et parfois il peut y
avoir une seule chaîne de production
donc s'il y a le moindre petit grain de
sable effectivement on ne peut plus
produire donc
comment comment vous expliquer ça
d'autre part
est-ce que vous ne pensez pas que vous
avez donc du fait de ce choix une
responsabilité éthique morale à
sécuriser justement ces chaînes ces
chaînes d'approvisionnement donc ça
c'est ma deuxième question sur des choix
stratégiques que vous avez fait et qui
explique en partie parce que bien
évidemment les pénuries ce serait trop
simpliste que de dire qu'il y a une
seule une seule cause aux pénuries de
médicaments ma deuxième question
concerne ma deuxième série de questions
concernent effectivement les prix vous
avez vous avez dit que les prix
notamment qui étaient trop bas en France
expliquait la difficulté pour vous de
maintenir une activité
soutenue dans cet état en France moi
j'aimerais que vous puissiez un peu plus
loin
cette cette remarque cette analyse
puisque nous avons reçu nous avons
auditionné plusieurs personnalités
plusieurs
institutions et notamment
Nathalie coutinet qui nous a dit que la
différence de prix avec l'Allemagne
était lié au taux de TVA et à la Binche
qui était faite et qui était par exemple
supérieur en Allemagne donc les choses
ne sont pas si simple me semble-t-il que
ce que vous pouvez vous pouvez nous
avoir mis en exergue en plus par
ailleurs plutôt il y a également la
corcadre avec le CPAS qui permet aux
entreprises de demander des hausses de
prix dans les cas justement où il y a
risque de
rupture donc pourquoi est-ce que vous
n'avez pas davantage recours à cette
procédure puisque on peut se plaindre
parfois des lenteurs de la mise en
application d'un certain nombre de
mesures mais une fois qu'elles sont
qu'elles sont là pourquoi est-ce que
nous les mettez pas en mouvement madame
madame Pinon vous avez évoqué le
déremboursement
quel est l'ampleur du phénomène et
combien de médicaments sont concernés
d'après vous pourraient être concerné
d'après vous
au niveau des donc ça c'était sur sur
les prix par ailleurs j'aimerais aussi
vous entendre sur le fait que
les aides qui sont données à la
recherche et au développement
je pense que vous souhaitez tous la
pérennisation du cyan qui est un apport
extrêmement important et en même temps
si on prend connaissance du rapport de
France stratégique ce rapport atteste le
fait que c'est le
constitue une aubaine par rapport aux
autres pays de l'OCDE pour le dire
autrement la France dépense plus en RD
privé par rapport à son PIB de tous les
pays de l'OCDE donc je pense que là
aussi ça serait intéressant d'avoir
votre point de vue puisque les aides
publiques de à la R&D sont plus de deux
fois plus importantes que la moyenne des
pays de l'Union européenne je donne ces
éléments là parce qu'ils sont
extrêmement importants quand on nous dit
que finalement c'est le prix des
médicaments qui expliquerait les
ruptures d'approvisionnement c'est le
manque d'aide publique ou de
sollicitations publiques qui pourraient
exprimer expliquer les choses on voit
bien là qu'il y a quand même des données
qui sont à relativiser je le dis
d'autant plus que il m'a semblé dans vos
propos liminaires que vous souhaitiez
ardemment effectivement participer à la
relocalisation en France mais qui dit
relocalisation en France un certain
nombre d'industries dit effectivement
aussi le fait de prendre en charge ce
que ça implique en termes de production
c'est en production de médicaments mais
en respectant évidemment les normes
sanitaires mais aussi les normes
environnementales or ça a un coût et
c'est sûr que au niveau des exigences
qu'il peut y avoir en France comme dans
l'ensemble des pays européens elles sont
beaucoup plus importantes que les
exigences qui peut y avoir aujourd'hui
en Inde ou en Chine donc j'aimerais bien
que vous ayez vous nous donniez des
éléments sur cette sur cette question là
donc voilà ça c'est les premières
questions que j'ai envie de vous poser
et suivant les réponses peut-être que
j'aurais une autre série de questions et
puis ensuite il y a bien sûr et ou en
même temps il y a mes collègues que je
ne veux pas frustré
donnons aussi la parole au collègue j'ai
deux demandes de parole en complément
sur un deuxième ronde de questions ça
signifie que le premier rang de réponse
doit être assez concentré et dense même
si les sujets sont vastes je vous
remercie
je pense que on aura l'occasion de
répondre aussi dans le questionnaire que
vous nous adresserez je suis très
heureux que Madame coutinet servent de
référence au Sénat pour l'élaboration
des chiffres je pense qu'on est un peu
mieux placé en tant que l'industriel
pour vous donner les données il y a
récemment une étude suédoise par exemple
qui vient d'être publié et qui se
rapportait à votre connaissance et qui
établit que les prix net français sont
parmi les plus bas d'Europe s'agissant
des produits matures et qu'on est à des
niveaux qui sont très très inférieurs
notamment au prix allemand et d'autre
part comme je le disais
vous avez observé comme nous que les
Lapi comme l'Allemagne mais aussi la
Suède et le Portugal ont décidé de
revaloriser le prix de ces produits
matures donc je conteste évidemment ces
chiffres et nous vous produirons tous
les tous les éléments qui vous
permettent de l'apprécier
deuxième élément
s'agissant des hausses de prix c'est un
article qui figure dans la cour 4 mais
qui n'a pas été appliqué ou qu'il est
extrêmement peu c'est à dire le nombre
de situations dans lesquelles il y a eu
à des augmentations de prix sont sont
plus faible c'est d'ailleurs un sujet
dont nous nous ouvrons régulièrement
avec notre partenaire conventionnelle
qui est le comité économique des
produits de santé sur la problématique
des remboursements que vous évoquiez
mais je laisserai peut-être mais mes
collègues répondent juste un mot pour
vous dire que ce qu'il faut bien
comprendre et ça c'est vraiment le point
essentiel c'est que la politique du
médicament est en train de craquer par
tous les bouts et il faut que la
représentation parlementaire en soit
consciente nous avons pris au mois de
janvier une décision unique nous avons
décidé de mettre en place un
observatoire de l'accès dire que nous
avons décidé de publier des données qui
permettent d'objectiver les difficultés
croissantes que nous avons en France
pour permettre l'accès aux médicaments
qu'il s'agisse des médicaments matures
mais aussi des médicaments innovants il
s'agit pas pour nous d'opposer les uns
aux autres quand vous regardez la
situation de l'innovation elle est tout
aussi problématique il y a d'ailleurs un
excellent rapport sénatorial qui avait
été fait par même la sénatrice de roche
sur le sujet qui établissait très bien
toutes les difficultés qu'il y avait en
matière d'accès à l'innovation dans ce
pays sur les 15 dernières années les
cinq nouveaux anti psychotiques qui sont
apparus ne sont pas rentrés sur le
marché français les nouveaux anti
migraines ne rentrent pas sur le marché
français récemment vous avez la
commission de transparence qui a rendu
un avis qui ne va pas permettre ce
remboursement sur des thérapies
orphelines dans le cancer donc les
situations extrêmement problématiques je
reviens en un mot sur la question vous
posiez on a en parler beaucoup de la
clause de sauvegarde vous avez voté le
PLFSS la clause de sauvegarde
initialement c'est un dispositif qui est
fait pour garantir le respect des
objectifs fixés par le Parlement dans le
vote de la LFSS
cette cause de sauvegarde historiquement
elle se situe dans un montant les années
où elle se déclenche de 150 à 200
millions d'euros
en 2021 la clause de sauvegarde sera 800
millions d'euros on a maintenant les
chiffres en 2022 d'après nos estimations
elle sera autour d'un milliard 3 la DSS
est à 1 milliard nous avons 300 millions
d'écart mais elle sera au dessus du
milliard et en 2000 et en 2023 on
devrait être au-dessus de 2 milliards
donc ça n'est plus une clause de
sauvegarde c'est une taxation
supplémentaire sur le secteur qui a déjà
la fiscalité la plus lourde d'Europe et
nous avons une étude qu'on produira qui
est une étude faite par un cabinet
extérieur qui s'appelle Landwell et
qu'il démontre à l'évidence sur le
crédit d'un pour cherche je conteste
formellement l'idée que le crédit
d'impôt recherche souhaite une aide le
crédit n'a pour cher c'est un dispositif
qui vient sanctionner le fait qu'on ait
fait un choix d'investissement en France
donc c'est pas du tout une aide au sens
où vous l'entendez la recherche en
France la recherche privée et financée
par le public je sais que c'est un vieux
débat que nous avons pour à peu près 1%
de son montant par contre la recherche
privée l'industrie privée finance très
largement la recherche publique
française nous finançons très largement
les équipes de recherche de l'Inserm les
équipes de recherche du CEA les équipes
de recherche du CNRS et les montants
sont sans comparaison mais le Seigneur
c'est une incitation fiscale ça n'est
pas une aide je crois qu'il faut pas
mélanger pardon
répondre à la première question de
Madame la rapporteur sur les
délocalisations en fait les entreprises
françaises du G5 santé ont maintenu leur
retiens industriel en France et en
Europe on a 53
usines en France donc notre sujet à nous
c'est plutôt d'arriver à garder
l'existant et maintenir ce que nous
avons maintenu en France en terme
d'usine et d'avoir une politique
industrielle et budgétaire qui nous
permettent de rester en France et un des
soucis que nous avons eu tout début de
la pandémie par contre c'est bien
d'avoir les usines en France et en
Europe il faut qu'elle puisse tourner et
le problème plutôt de
l'approvisionnement en flacon en unrant
en matière première c'était ça vraiment
notre gros sujet nos présidents ont
réuni un groupe de travail à des
directeurs des achats et des directeurs
des affaires industriels de nos 8
entreprises au niveau mondial pour
réfléchir sur nos fragilités et essayer
de trouver des solutions en leur
demandant de diversifier nos
fournisseurs ne pas être dépendant d'un
seul fournisseur et d'essayer d'avoir au
moins 3 quand c'est possible parfois
c'est pas possible d'en avoir trois et
sur les trois de n'avoir au moins deux
en Europe c'est quand même mieux de les
avoir proches du territoire nation al
que des avoir à l'autre bout du monde ça
a été quand même la politique a été
décidé au niveau du G5 on maintient nos
usines et par contre on diversifie les
sources d'approvisionnement en essayant
d'avoir plutôt des fournisseurs en amont
des chimistes décédés etc qui soit près
de nos centres de décisions en France ou
en Europe
oui de même pour les PME nous aussi on
produit en France donc on n'a pas du
tout de délocalisation comme comme vous
le disiez et néanmoins on fait face
aussi à des ruptures de stock donc pour
dire que la délocalisation n'est pas
forcément synonyme de la responsabilité
de la rupture juste pour vous répondre
sur la question du du des remboursement
nous au sein de la niche on a fait un
petit un petit sondage on dirait on dira
qu'on a à peu près 10% de portefeuille
du produit de la miss qui sont
aujourd'hui sujet à questionnement parce
que non viable économiquement et du coup
question de se dire est-ce qu'on arrête
de commercialiser ces produits ou est-ce
qu'on continue à les commercialiser en
les dérembourçant et là c'est un choix
de l'industriel c'est pas un choix qui
est avec une décision du CEPS ou de
l'achats
oui pour revenir sur la question des
prix et de du point de vue de Madame
coutinier elle ne peut avoir accès qu'à
des prix faciaux en Allemagne le prix
nous connaissons les règles qui font que
le prix faciale est décoté pour avoir le
prix net d'un certain pourcentage qui
est connu et il n'y a pas ensuite de
remise supplémentaires en France il y a
une énorme différence entre le prix
faciale que vous voyez en pharmacie et
le prix net qui est le résultat d'un
accord avec le CEPS et il suffit de lire
les rapports du CEPS pour voir qu'au fil
des années le montant des remises qui
représente en fait ce cet écart entre
prix faciale et primette n'a cessé de
croître le dernier montant atteignant à
peu près 5 milliards d'euros ce qui est
absolument colossal et qui n'a cessé
d'augmenter donc en réalité les les prix
que vous voyez facturés ne sont pas les
prix officiels catalogues ne sont pas
les prix nets et le monde l'écart la
vitesse d'augmenter donc je pense qu'en
fait on a un vrai sujet un vrai sujet
aujourd'hui sur la discussion sur le
prix parce que tout le monde ne regarde
que des prix qui sont les prix
catalogues et ne connaît pas les vrais
primettes qui sont qui sont signés avec
le CEPS donc je pense que ça c'est vrai
qu'il faut s'appuyer sur des études plus
fines et où on voit que la France sur
les quatre moi je peux le voir avec mes
collègues des autres pays les prix nette
en France sont toujours pour un même
produit les plus bas de toute l'Europe
je crois qu'il y avait une question sur
les principes actifs pour lequel vous
attendiez une réponse alors 80% c'est un
chiffre évidemment qu'on entend il me
semble qu'il parle de du principe actif
mondial alors je ne connais pas le
chiffre rapporté aux activités
françaises mais pour le l'industrie que
je représente on estime que 50% au moins
des principes actifs utilisés ont des
sources européennes ou internationales
or chiens et si on parle de ces deux
pays là mais ne contestons pas le
mouvement effectivement il y a eu un
mouvement autour de 30 années qui a
permis à cette industrie chimique de se
développer plus dans ces dans ces
pays-là comme beaucoup d'autres
industries manufacturières que l'on
connaît qui n'ont rien à voir avec la
pharmacie
c'est un chiffre à prendre avec des
pincettes parce que en fonction des
médicaments on va pas avoir les mêmes
ratios évidemment si on prend un produit
comparé à l'autre ce ne sera pas la même
chose choses mais le constat est là un
constat qu'on a souligné on parle ici de
la chimie des principes actifs voire de
composants de sources des principes
actifs en revanche à ne pas confondre
avec l'industrie manufacturière donc la
pharmacie une
usine de production dont nous disons
qu'il reste un réseau en France qui est
probablement réduit par rapport à
quelques années mais que nous appelons à
soutenir aussi recoller la localiser oui
soutenir aussi ce réseau là et soutenir
aussi le réseau industriel européen qui
fournit la grande majorité des produits
consommés en Europe je fais la
différence entre la chimie et la
pharmacie donc voilà pour l'analyse
maintenant le constat vous l'avez posé
en termes de responsabilité d'éthique je
pense que ceci n'a pas été fait dans le
dos ou de manière cachée ce sont des
évolutions lentes qui ont lieu des
opportunités d'enregistrer des principes
actifs qui sont conformes aux normes
connus nos autorités
auditées
transparence et données sur l'ensemble
de nos chaînes d'approvisionnement donc
voilà je pense que c'est une une
information qui était partagée est
connue et un mouvement dont on peut
s'inquiéter aujourd'hui à l'aune de
nouvelles relations internationales
très bien merci beaucoup madame la
rapporteur après
Pascal Grigny puis à la Milan
donc moi c'est toujours pour poursuivre
parce que effectivement quand on quand
on dit
il y a des causes multiples au ruptures
et aux pénuristes évident donc faut pas
simplifier les choses
en même temps on voit et c'est pas
seulement parce que je pense que quand
on auditionne les personnes elles sont
sous serment quand on ne disent quelques
personnes que ce soit du lait ou autre
et bien elle nous fournissent un certain
nombre d'éléments et c'est pas seulement
madame coutinhley qui nous a parlé des
prix et qui a qui a défendu ce que je
viens de vous rapporter on s'aperçoit
aussi que il y a tous les pays européens
quel que soit les prix pratiqués ont
connu des des pénuries et des ruptures
donc
il faut expliquer aussi c'est de ces
données là et moi je voudrais justement
là dessus vous interrogez les
entreprises sont contraintes aujourd'hui
à organiser à produire des plans de
gestion de pénurie
pour chacun des médicaments d'intérêt
thérapeutique majeurs alors on pourrait
discuter mais ça serait trop long pour
être discuter de l'intérêt ou pas de
réduire la liste la liste des
médicaments d'intérêt thérapeutiques
majeurs il y a plusieurs interlocuteurs
depuis le début qui nous qui nous qui
attire notre attention là-dessus mais là
n'est pas la question donc pour certains
médicaments et d'après l'Agence
nationale de sécurité du médicament que
nous avons auditionné la qualité des PGP
qui est qu'il aurait transmis et
particulièrement inégale ça n'est pas
normal comment est-ce que vous expliquez
cela et comment du coup responsabiliser
davantage les entreprises dans
l'anticipation et la gestion
et la gestion des des pénuries ça ça me
paraît quand même un élément et le
deuxième élément si vous madame qui m'y
avait fait songer parce que j'avais ma
question mais je l'avais mise de côté
concernant les prix etc les difficultés
je crois qu'il y a on a il y a un très
lourd handicap au niveau de la politique
du médicament c'est le manque de
transparence le manque de transparence
que tout le monde peut subir concernant
justement les prix concernant le fait
que il y a il y ait des tensions au
niveau des stocks par exemple nous
savons que les stocks qui sont se sont
seulement des déclaratifs et qui a pas
de moyens de contrôle ça nous a été dit
en audition qui a pas suffisamment de
moyens de contrôle c'est pas qu'il y en
a pas on pourrait avoir des moyens de
contrôle mais on est obligé un peu de
croire sur déclaration ce qui est dit et
parfois ça peut aussi être une des
explications là encore pas là pas la
seule ça serait trop simpliste
Pascal Bruni
moi j'ai une question d'abord sur la
clause de sauvegarde mais vous y avez
bien répondu et je vous en remercie moi
je voudrais savoir si le fait d'avoir
ces diminutions en fait de marge et donc
de résultats joue sur les
investissements
particulièrement et puis pour lever des
questions douteuses ce matin on nous a
dit que les dividendes sur les résultats
de notre grand laboratoire français tu
es passé 35% à 50 %, si vous pouvez
lever lever ça parce que j'espère qu'il
y a d'abord les investissements bien
entendu
sur ce qu'on appelle la fluide des
cerveaux parce que je me je me doute que
ça ça joue aussi parce que
les salaires en France et contenus aussi
du fait que vous n'avez plus les marges
aussi importantes il y a des
concurrences ailleurs et donc forcément
c'est très humain d'aller parfois là où
la rémunération est plus importante et
après
monsieur c'est Monsieur Borel je crois
vous avez parlé de l'optimisation des
chaînes d'approvisionnement
donc ça on comprend bien parce que c'est
c'est essentiel mais en revanche même la
boisson vous avez dit qu'il fallait
avoir des sites en fait qui qui soient
capables d'absorber finalement une
production qui est devenue urgente donc
ça veut dire que l'optimisation est pas
forcément faite de ce côté-là et que
vous avez peut-être des chaînes qui
tournent pas je dirais à fond et qui
peuvent justement absorber ça et donc
l'incohérence pas de souci parce que moi
je comprends bien que si c'était
possible de faire comme vous dites ce
serait tout simple mais que les raisons
financières bien sûr sont là merci
et pour finir à la million
oui merci Madame
moi je vais pas poser de questions je
vais juste faire un petit constat
j'aimerais d'abord vous dire que on ne
peut pas demander aux Entreprises du
Médicament d'être responsables elles le
sont déjà en fait elles ne peuvent pas
être plus responsables que l'État
lui-même dans notre pays malheureusement
et je pense qu'on va être d'accord sur
le sujet il n'y a pas de vrai politique
du médicament et tout le temps qu'on
aura pas mis en place une vraie
politique de médicaments avec une vision
dans le temps pour les laboratoires en
particulier pour l'industrie
pharmaceutique en particulier quand je
divisions dans le temps c'est-à-dire on
peut pas dire c'est moi 700 millions
cette année moi un milliard l'année
prochaine moins de l'année prochaine
moins 300 millions dans 5 ans c'est
complètement illisible pour tout le
monde et ça ne permet pas d'avoir une
vraie politique de mise en place des
différents systèmes que que vous mettez
en place donc moi ce que je voudrais
c'est qu'on est une vraie politique de
médicaments qu'on arrête de
responsabiliser les uns et les autres
nous sommes tous responsables mais vous
êtes vous dans vos responsabilités de
très haute qualité j'ai rien à redire
sur le sujet en fait je voudrais
redire quelque chose qui me semble être
une mauvaise habitude qui est prise dans
la population on dit souvent que les
médecins les professionnels de santé
laboratoires pharmaceutique sont payés
par l'assurance maladie et par les
mutuelles non absolument pas l'assurance
maladie est mutuelle rembourse ce qui
devrait être payé par le patient donc en
fait elle ne paye que le patient pour
que le patient puisse se soigner c'est
une différence importante
donc il nous reste peu de temps je
voulais juste réagir sur deux choses le
coût de la baguette c'est pas tout à
fait le même mode de financement que le
médicament ça c'est voilà non mais c'est
juste
l'argent vient pas du même endroit et
par arbitrer de la même façon et l'autre
chose c'est que la santé c'est un bien
public et que le médicament est un des
outils de la mise en oeuvre de ce bien
public et que donc à ce titre là il a un
rôle particulier c'est pas un bien de
consommation ordinaire et même si les
problématiques économiques des
entreprises s'entend tout à fait et
elles sont tout à fait dans leur rôle
parce qu'elles fournissent aussi ce bien
de santé publique mais il n'empêche que
du point de vue des pouvoirs publics il
y a un rôle particulier à jouer et
peut-être des arbitrages à négocier à
prévoir notamment concernant le prix du
médicament et les politiques de santé
publique et leur financement qui sont
nécessaires à mettre en oeuvre et à ce
titre là il y a une légitimité aussi à
avoir un regard si ce n'est comment dire
attentif en tout cas adapté aux
financement des politiques de santé et
donc du médicament
sur un petit peu impertinent parce que
une fois que le tarif de remboursement
est fixé entre le labo et le CEPS
est-ce qu'il y a pas de temps à autre je
vais me dire comme ça une une remise
commerciale qui est qui est accordée et
si oui comment l'expliquez-vous alors
que les industriels se plaignent
justement de prix trop bas donc à la
fois il y a des remises commerciales
dans certains cas et en même temps vous
plaignez de de
prix trop bas comment vous expliquer ça
et je fais une remarque qu'effectivement
faut que tout le monde soit devant ses
responsabilités nous en tant que
parlementaire nos responsabilités c'est
de voter l'ONDAM et il est en baisse
chaque année
je rappelle
il faudra que vous réinviter une session
d'une heure et demie parce que là les
questions que vous nous posez nous
emmènent vraiment très loin
on peut vous prendre au mot
avec un grand plaisir peut-être pour je
vais répondre un petit peu dans le
désordre mais mais en m'excusant d'abord
j'ai précieux j'ai envie de vous
remercier de votre question madame
madame le rapporteur parce que
effectivement là où je vous rejoins
c'est que il est absolument anormal que
nous ayons cette discussion sur les prix
nettes des médicaments dans les brevets
sont tombés
et ça c'est pour moi un véritable
facteur et je peux vous garantir que
nous nous sommes demandeurs d'avoir une
métrologie commune avec l'assurance
maladie avec le payeur pour que les
chiffres soient des chiffres partagés et
objectivés sous double timbre c'est pour
vous dire à quel point nous sommes
confiants sur la certitude que nous
avons sur les prix nets des produits
dont les brevets sont tombés et je pense
que effectivement il y a une une opacité
entretenue qui n'est pas de notre fête
qui permet de contester ce que nous
disons à chaque fois on nous évoquant
des chiffres qui ne correspondent pas à
la réalité que nous observons et ça
c'est quelque chose on vous a donné des
chiffres on se donnait des tarifs de
remboursement des coûts de revient je
parle des produits dans les brevets sont
tombés parce que là évidemment
tout est sur la table
là vous avez je vous rejoins tout à fait
deuxième élément sur la problématique de
la fuite des cerveaux
moi c'est pas ça qui me pardonnez-moi à
c'est pas ça qui me préoccupe ce qui me
préoccupe c'est cette espèce de
schizophrénie politique du médicament où
on a d'un côté des politiques
industrielles extrêmement volontariste
et ou de l'autre côté on détruit le
marché c'est-à-dire que en réalité le
vrai problème c'est qu'il faut
comprendre qu'il y a un moment nous
avons et vous l'avez dit monsieur le
sénateur un problème de gouvernance de
la politique du médicament dans ce pays
où on met en place des mécanismes
d'incentive industriels ou de l'autre
côté on ne gère pas les problématiques
d'accès et les problématiques de
tarification du médicament or les deux
vont ensemble donc nous sommes arrivés à
un moment où le niveau de régulation est
tel que nous devons réconcilier les deux
exercices et mettre en place une
véritable gouvernance avec un pilote
unique de cette politique du médicament
sur les politiques sur les
problématiques de de stocks et de et de
et de PGP vous avez vous avez raison moi
je regardais ce qui a été fait depuis
quelques années
la gestion les PGP la gestion et
ruptures ne mobilise de plus en plus les
moyens c'est d'ailleurs contrôlé par la
NSM
pour plus une spécialité sur deux on
recourt au contingentement avec parfois
arrêt du circuit de ville pour prioriser
circuit hospitalier on a mis en place
des stocks de dépannage d'urgence on a
mis en place une politique de message
direct au grossiste répartiteur pour
interrompre la vente de produits à
l'étranger on a mis en oeuvre des
actions d'information et
d'accompagnement des professionnels de
santé via la NSM ou via le déperuptures
je sais que vous avez reçu les les
pharmaciens d'officine on contacte
directement les associations de patients
pour les informer des situations on
réoriente les lots initialement destinée
à d'autres marchés voir des lots de
laboratoire concurrents et donc on est
extrêmement actif et vous verrez nous
rendrons tous la public dans quelques
semaines que nous allons contribuer au
plan rupture du gouvernement en faisant
des propositions il y a cinq ou six
propositions qui semblent assez clair ça
a été dit nous avons besoin d'une liste
des médicaments critiques à sécuriser de
façon prioritaire et il faut que
derrière venir cette liste de
médicaments critiques soit adossé un
dispositif de financement spécifique ce
qui n'est pas le cas à ma connaissance
aujourd'hui et si possible et si la
représentation sénatoriale peut nous
aider que cette liste soit une liste
européenne c'est à dire qu'on n'est pas
une liste allemande ça c'est un premier
point deuxième point et ça a été dit
aussi nous pensons qu'il faut optimiser
la transparence et la qualité de
l'information entre les acteurs nous
devons avoir une meilleure visibilité
sur les états des stocks des médicaments
en tension ou en rupture selon la chaîne
et nous ne vont diffuser une information
fiable par exemple aujourd'hui nous
avons une obligation de stockage dont on
a beaucoup parlé nous n'avons pas
connaissance des stocks des grossistes
répartiteurs qui ne sont pas inclus dans
l'obligation de stockage et qui ne sont
pas visibles pour nos industriels nous
avons besoin de mobiliser les autorités
sur des mesures d'optimisation
réglementaires
il faut fluidifier la production ça a
été dit évitez les transferts de stocks
entre l'état de l'Union et et donc
lutter contre les d'exportation
parallèle et avoir des réglementations
qui soient qui soit
harmonisés là encore et spécifique aux
médicaments
assouplissement réglementaire mise en
place de la hypnotis interdiction des
exportations pour les médicaments
signalés en tension et pas les
médicaments en rupture
anticiper les impacts déréglementations
environnementales sur la disponibilité
des médicaments il faut faire quatrième
point converger la législation en Europe
je vais vous donner un exemple parce que
j'adore le citer parce que je pense
qu'il est très parlant nous avons 27
États membres dans l'Europe combien de
calendriers vaccinaux
23 ça veut dire que quand il y a une
rupture d'approvisionnement de vaccin
en France on ne peut pas importer de
vaccins belge
renforcer le rôle de la France dans le
réel la révision de la législation
pharmaceutique européenne qui doit être
l'occasion de porter ses sujets
assurer une fois encore donc une
Européenne initiation de cette
problématique des ruptures il faut
redimension redynamiser l'investissement
et pérenniser l'outil industriel on l'a
dit ça a été longuement évoqué on a
parlé de l'article 65 on a parlé de
l'article 28 on pourrait aussi imaginer
utiliser la fiscalité de façon un peu
plus attractive qu'elle de l'Est ou
mieux ou mieux reconnaître des
investissements enfin on a parlé des
conditions économiques il faut mettre en
place des mesures d'urgence pour les
médicaments situation de vulnérabilité
économique et par dessus tout ça une
gouvernance qui souhaite une gouvernance
claire je le redis nous avons le
sentiment que nous avons une gouvernance
du médicament en France qui était
schizophrène entre d'un côté la
politique industrielle et de l'autre
côté les régulateurs il faut réconcier
les exercices faire des choix clairs
avoir des priorités et les assumer
politiquement dernier élément sur les
données chiffrées je rappelle quand même
que sur les 10 dernières années et là
encore on vous produira les chiffres la
dépense de médicaments a été totalement
contenue a été totalement privé de
croissance et qu'elle a été en quelque
sorte la variable d'ajustement des ondes
successifs
voulait juste poser une question de plus
excusez-moi merci Madame une ou deux
remarques et puis une question s'il vous
plaît
je partage
très rapide donc je vous remercie des
propositions que vous venez de rappeler
à l'instant de
je dis depuis un certain temps que notre
système de santé est en train de nous
exploser à la figure ou nous filer entre
les doigts vous savez dit que la
politique du médicament craquait par
tous les bouts si je reprends vos propos
malheureusement je partage aussi un
petit peu cette analyse et qu'il fallait
voir la gouvernance et l'assumer et
c'est quand même le point de départ de
tout ça sans refaire l'histoire rappelée
que depuis 35 ans
le médicament était la seule variable
d'ajustement
du financement de la sécurité sociale et
qu'à l'époque le défi de la sécurité
sociale tout ce qui remettent des choses
dans le contexte étaient un des deux
critères de bonne gestion avec le taux
de chômage de bonne d'un gouvernement
quel qu'il soit on avait deux chiffres
le taux de chômage et le déficit par mes
chiffres régulièrement donné et le
déficit de la Sécu et les taux de
chômage et que c'était après il y a une
deuxième variable justement c'était
l'hôpital c'est à dire qu'à un moment on
avait le coup de rabot qu'on a toujours
sur le médicament et après il y a eu le
coup de rabot sur sur l'hôpital les
coups de rabot sur l'hôpital et on sait
où ça nous conduit donc
soit effectivement on assume une
politique du médicament avec un système
de sécurité sociale qui rembourse aux
patient sans que le patient est
d'ailleurs eu des
des deux critères de bonne gestion avec
le taux de chômage de bonnes gestion
d'un gouvernement quel qu'il soit on
avait deux chiffres le taux de chômage
et le déficit enfin par mes chiffres
régulièrement donné et le défi de la
Sécu et le taux de chômage et que
c'était après il y a une deuxième
variable de justement c'était l'hôpital
c'est à dire qu'à un moment on avait le
coup de rabot qu'on a toujours sur le
médicament et après il y a eu le coup de
rabot sur sur l'hôpital les coups de
rabots sur l'hôpital et on sait où ça
nous conduit donc
soit effectivement on assume une
politique du médicament avec un système
de sécurité sociale qui rembourse au
patience sans que le patient est
d'ailleurs eu des
de médicaments les pénuries etc touchent
les produits matures pas les produits
innovants ça doit quand même faire
réfléchir à tout le monde
première chose la deuxième chose
effectivement le marché français est
compliqué etc mais on n'a pas du tout
abordé une chose qui est quand même
extrêmement attractive sur le marché
français c'est le volume
parce qu'il est très conséquent et la
troisième chose mais nous allons aller à
Bercy donc nous aurons nous aurons des
éléments chiffrés donc ça voilà comme ça
on sera on sera d'accord sur ces
éléments mais on n'a pas abordé par
exemple l'excédent brut d'exploitation
donc je pourrais parler j'ai quelques
exemples notamment de labo du G5 et il y
a une certaine marge conséquente qui sur
laquelle on pourrait débattre donc voilà
il y a des choses qu'on n'a pas abordé
ça sera ça fera peut-être le l'objet de
de questionnaire peut-être
éventuellement d'ailleurs d'une autre
encore audition mais je pense que c'est
important et en tout cas on va y compris
auditionner les différents ministres
merci beaucoup de voilà de vous
contributions de cet échange qui a
débordé et qui semble ne pas vouloir
s'arrêter donc on attend beaucoup de vos
contributions écrites et notamment sur
ces questions de chiffre d'affaires
mettre en perspective la France dans le
cadre européen et dans le cadre mondial
parce qu'on sait que l'économie malgré
tout des médicaments reste très
mondialisés et que ce sujet là ne peut
pas être complètement déconnecté de la
problématique de la pénurie en France
voilà je vous remercie beaucoup